okay 594 Frank over Henry
show us your hands
on a request for an object named Tracy
different phone numbers for both
Temple we got contact
male-driven all coming out talking to us
is everyone inside okay
okay bring him out
do you need EMS
negative
turn around turn around turn around you
got me covered
all right just put your hands behind
your back I'm not going to Cuff you
right now do you have any weapons on you
or anything sharp nope yeah
I was playing Rainbow Six Siege inside
what's your name Bud okay you can relax
okay so this was just an accident you
called 9-1-1 but did you say you killed
two people or something like that yeah
okay how old are you 17. you're 17. do
you have a driver's license or no oh no
okay
where's your parents at uh work okay
just hold on hold on a second okay do
you care if we just check make sure
everybody's okay nobody's in the house
it's quite dogs away I have two German
Shepherds inside okay
um
outside of the dog though
Elijah what's your last name Bud uh
Elijah Matthew
and what's your date of birth
okay
yeah can you call your mom for me
hello thank you he said no they're not
friendly
okay
about
yeah there are four of them right here I
was playing the game I had my headset on
and uh I butt dialed the police officer
on accident and I I just you know from
the game you know how I acted up in the
game and so four of them came here
do you want me to talk to your mom uh
yeah you got any trouble man all right
if it's an accident is this Elijah's Mom
okay yeah okay so what happened is I
guess he's saying that he was playing a
video game and in the process of
accidentally calling 9-1-1 he said that
he killed two people but he was talking
about on the game so we thought that
there was a double murder so we showed
up to your house with a bunch of us
that's why we're here talking to your
son okay so there's nothing to be
worried about
okay yeah we're just trying to we're
just doing our due diligence here trying
to figure everything out make sure that
everybody's okay because we have to do
that when we get a 9-1-1 call so we just
wanted to inform you
um are you nearby or no
[Music]
house if that's okay okay just to make
sure that
dogs yeah yeah your son was telling us
that the dogs need to be put up first so
I just wanted to talk to you before so
we can get your permission okay yeah
that's totally fine all righty well
thank you very much
bye
all right here we go away come inside
okay hold on for me let me just get my
supervisor on on speed with us here hey
we can go in put the dogs up check the
house and go 10-8 okay
if you have questions about what's
happening yeah let's go in we're just
gonna go and put the dogs up and check
the house real quick please
foreign
[Music]
okay well we're just gonna look around
real quick all right if you just want to
hang out in the kitchen
okay thank you bud
Boone County Sheriff's Office anybody in
here
hey I'm going upstairs
Boone County Sheriff's Office anybody
upstairs
office anybody in here
[Music]
[Music]
Boone County Sheriff's Office anybody in
here
[Music]
yeah upstairs Claire
downstairs
not available
yet yeah I've got it
do you go to uh Cooper
I was in I was in different school but
now I'm going to a meeting on Friday to
go to Boone oh they're good okay so you
will be going to Boone soon okay and
it's e-l-i-j-a-h last name is Matthew
Rocky how do you spell soraki
okay
yeah those both German Shepherds yes sir
I like German Shepherds
when they shut a lot but they're there
oh yeah yeah I know I've had I've had
two in my time
uh
all right
where are you playing Siege any good uh
I'm level 106 so wait he killed two
people yeah
[Laughter]
do you need anything else to pass on
Rhonda yeah
[Music]
thank you
what is the channel reopened is the
channel open yeah
all right we'll be right back
I don't think we need anything else I
mean even if we're doing a show I don't
think we need a statement for him he was
the subject so now did anybody get your
driver I got his info yeah okay
okay it's for us buddy
buddy he's being cool you know right
when you come we
I don't I'm sure everybody
came out we knew you're being
cooperative with us I appreciate you
coming out even though it wasn't easy
yeah I I walked over there and saw two
cop cars and I looked over here I saw
something
what did I do did I miss school
they were serious about that I know
they're scared the hell out of me but
yeah
yeah but um I sorry you had to deal with
this I appreciate you being cool yeah do
you want to shoot the breeze with us one
day just give us a call man but um if
you need anything at all your mom does
just give us a call okay yeah thank you
thank you thank you
I appreciate it take care buddy
all right
box guys
together
yep
no worries
all right is he good he's good you
didn't everything I saw was always a
little already yeah everybody was at low
ready as far as handle of care and
that's all really man
I don't care who handles it I'll take
care of it it should be cut and dry yeah
I'll take it okay I'll take care of it
tonight is he everything seems to be
okay I just wanted to let you guys know
so because I'm gonna go around front
they had a break in though no
what swatting my channel
sorry they were calling us yeah there's
some kid playing video games and it
appears to be something similar to that
so it's not going to be a big deal but
we're gonna figure the rest of that out
all right